a man who loved life a phrase built for
fifty four-year-old Lani's and eager he
let the Philippines twelve years ago and
travel to the UK to work as a nurse in
Phoenix Omaha not been attending for a
little more than lan-evo young NASA
issue proposal for his family never
imagined this would be his last recorded
video message to them after three weeks
in intensive care
he died on Friday after testing positive
for the corona virus he wanted to be
with him during his last days but we
can't do anything like how hard it was
to watch her that you know during his
last moments I just wanted to thank him
for all the sacrifices you know just to
give us a better life and for all the
service and for risking his life from
his hospital bed this was the last time
Lonnie was seen alive
the nurse who worked in a care home is
the latest victim of a pandemic claiming
the lives of Filipino health care
workers Arnold a friend of Lonnie is
recovering from kovat 19 he went to see
him at his home just weeks before he was
admitted to hospital and believes that's
where he caught the virus even though I
was for example infected because of
coming to him I would have been thankful
if he survived I mean at least we
survived together but you know you have
invested a lot you went there and you
risk your life still he died that's
something that broke my heart
the pain is war for Arnold in the last
month he's lost Oscar and Albert two men
who worked as hospital porters for the
NHS Filipinos especially frontline
workers have been hardest hit by this
pandemic Sky News has learned they
account for nearly 20 percent of all
deaths involving NHS and social care
cuz why are there so many Filipino
health care workers dying here in the UK
part of the reason why a lot of our
health care workers are being hit it's
because of the inadequate personal
protective equipment that they are being
given I think they are not well equipped
when they are sent to the front lines of
this war and I hope that the authorities
would will do something for Lonnie's
family there will be a time for answers
for the questions they have
but for now they want him to be
remembered as a hero
no Philips Sky News